after a full year since we were told 15
days to slow the spread
in his address last night to the nation
president joe biden finally gave us a
timetable
on when we can reopen the country if we
do all this
if we do our part if we do this together
by july the 4th there's a good chance
you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together
after this long hard year that will make
this independence day
something truly special
where we not only mark our independence
as a nation
but we begin to mark our independence
from this virus
i think i'm going to mark my
independence from you and all the other
sociopath politicians who have the gall
to stand there i did the calculation
from last night
until july 4th they're saying that they
want
another 115 days to slow the spread
one year after 15 days to slow the
spread they want another 115 days to
slow the spread
how about we declare independence right
now i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knoll show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from irving
who says
no one absolutely no one
michael you know this reminds me of my
book that's true it does
it reminds me of my book i think this is
providential it's the sort of
silver lining in this storm cloud of our
politics right now
because coincidentally the book that
i've been writing for a year and a half
now which is coming out in june
is exactly about everything we're seeing
right now particularly
with the curtailment of our speech and
the banning of books and the utter
upending of our culture and our norms
you can get that book speechless
controlling words controlling minds you
can pre-order that
right now but as we will see a little
bit later you may not be able to
order it for very long because the
largest book seller in the world
is coming out and saying that
politically incorrect books
in many cases are not going to be
allowed
you know all these challenges
notwithstanding
i still keep a lot of hope i think that
the future is so bright
you got to wear shades and that's why i
love wearing my blue blocks
because with these shades i can block
out all that
harmful irritating blue light and much
more importantly
i can look extremely cool while i do it
blue light damages our eyes and leads to
digital eye strain symptoms of digital
eye strain are blurred vision headaches
and dry watery eyes
blue blocks was created to fix this
problem and block out the blue light
with high quality lenses
unlike other types of blue light glasses
blue blocks are evidence-based they are
made under optics laboratory conditions
in australia
the founders were unhappy with the
quality and lack of science behind
leading blue light blocking glasses
brands
blue blocks was created to change this
with high quality lenses for daytime
nighttime
and for color therapy exactly in line
with the suggested peer-reviewed
academic literature
they have over 40 hip frames they also
come in prescription non-prescription
and readers
i tell you you know i'm as skeptical as
anything of these sort of modern
scientific observations the blue light
thing is one that i'm totally convinced
on and actually have been convinced on
for years these actually make your eyes
feel much better they really reduce
strain
make it much easier particularly at
night go to blueblocks.com
knowles use the promo code knowles at
checkout to get 20 off and enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks
get your energy back sleep better and
block out the unhealthy effects
of blue light with blue blocks and also
most importantly look like an extremely
cool guy
go to blublox.com knowles make sure to
use codenos to get 20
off your order enjoy free shipping on
orders over 115 bucks
b-l-u-b-lox dot com slash knowles for 20
off today
go check out blue blocks very very cool
classes
the speech last night was absolutely
pathetic
if anybody
is still taking these people seriously
if anybody is still
heeding their guidelines which are
actually mandates
then that person is a dope and
most of us i think figured this out
quite a while ago
once that two weeks became three weeks
four weeks two months six months eight
months we
i think a lot of us realized oh this is
not
exactly what we were told this is oh
okay we're gonna stop paying attention
to these guys
when all the guidance kept changing day
by day by day i think a lot of us said
i think i'm going to ignore this now joe
biden
is carrying this on it would seem to me
because he needs to burnish his legacy
president trump did everything that one
can do
as pertains to the virus before he left
office
right slowing the spread that worked
they slowed the spread
preventing the two million deaths within
a year that we were told could happen
yeah prevented that obviously it was the
number was much lower than that
developed a vaccine we were told by
people such as joe biden
that there was no way that trump could
direct a vaccine initiative in the
small window of time that he said he
would we did get the vaccine in that
window of time
so he did everything now joe biden says
gosh what's there for me to do i need i
need to seem like
trump screwed up coronavirus and i
succeeded on coronavirus
so he's offering us something really
really big really important if you're
driving i would stop if you're standing
i would sit down right now here's big
joe biden's big innovation to help us
all survive coronavirus
at the time when every adult is eligible
in may
we will launch with our partners new
tools to make it easier for you to find
the vaccine
and where to get the shot including a
new website that will help you
first find the place to get vaccinated
and the one
nearest you stop the presses
we gotta i i need to stop my show right
now i need to process this huge news
that joe biden's gonna make a web page
joe biden the president of the united
states has
more resources at his fingertips than
anybody in the world he
is going to make a web page and what
on top of that you're going to get a web
page from the same people who brought
you the obamacare webpage
so i don't hire me to make the web page
and i will go to wordpress and i will
make
a more successful web page than probably
the federal government will
uh not so much isn't that that's that's
not so much of a big
advance on the fight against coronavirus
then
what's next we we're going to get a web
page because we all need to get the
vaccine it was very
interesting how much of a focus biden
put on you have to get the vaccine you
need to get all your friends to get the
vaccine everyone needs to get the
vaccine but also of course
you need to keep wearing masks that's
just the science
too often we've turned against one
another
a mask the easiest thing to do to save
lives
sometimes it divides us so our message
to you is this
listen to dr fauci one most
distinguished and trusted voices in the
world
can you believe that masks it's so easy
it's so obvious
saves lives you should just instantly
this is the first thing you should be
doing
that divides us that's become a divisive
question because people
don't listen to dr fauci the guy who
told us not to wear masks
now in the united states people should
not be walking around
with masks you're sure of it because
people are listening really
no closely to this right now people
should not be white there's no reason to
be walking around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people think
that it is and often there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
can you believe people are so divided
and they
they won't do the obvious sensible thing
and we're the mask
the people who are listening to dr fauci
who told them not to now dr fatchi of
course changed his mind on this
later he said no you really you should
wear the mask definitely wear the mask
and his reasoning for his his past
advice
was that he wanted to keep enough masks
for the healthcare
workers so he said yeah we didn't want
you peasants to take up all the good
masks we wanted those to be for the
the people in public health so but now
we have enough masks so now
yeah actually you totally should wear
masks everything i said before
just wasn't true so don't don't believe
that okay
regardless of your stance on the masks
if you're still wearing this filthy
cloth over your face in public like a
sheep
you know my views of it uh but
regardless let's say you wear it you
want to do it you want to do what joe
biden says
does joe biden not understand why people
might be a little skeptical
because the single expert
that he is holding up as the the
credible man here for the credibles
common sense advice
he's the one who not only first told us
not to wear them but
then admitted that he misled us he
admitted that he was acting in a way
that was political and
actually obscuring the scientific
reality
now beyond the masks beyond the website
joe biden knows we're going to get
through these dark dark times in our
country
by washing our hands we're seizing this
moment
in history i believe will record we
faced and overcame one of the toughest
and darkest periods in this nation's
history
darkest we've ever known we need
everyone to get vaccinated
we need everyone to keep washing their
hands
stay socially distanced and keep wearing
the mask
as recommended by the cdc
statesmanship in 1940s
winston churchill we shall go on we
should fight on the beaches and in the
streets
we shall never surrender
statesmanship in 2021 wear the mask
where the hat wear the mask wash your
hands
you got to wash your hands use soap and
water
warm water not cold water cold water is
not going to kill all the germs
gotta wear the mask gotta wash your
hands
the notion that this is the darkest
time in american history forgive me if i
think it's a little hyperbolic is it not
a little hyperbolic
the civil war it was pretty dark wasn't
it world war
ii both of the world wars pretty dark
time in our history
the i'm not i don't mean to downplay the
china cough
it's bad it is bad it really is bad
worse than that worse than the civil war
i don't
i don't think so i don't think he's
convincing anybody
meanwhile you've got these social
repercussions like the schools right the
schools
are still shut down kids rates of
anxiety depression even suicide are
spiking in a lot of places because they
can't see their friends they can't leave
their home they're stuck in their little
pods
joe biden he he's going to figure a way
out of this
watching a generation of children who
may be set back up to a year or more
because they've not been in school
because of their loss of learning
it's the details of life that matter
most
and we miss those details the big
details and the small moments
weddings birthdays graduations
all the things that needed to happen but
didn't
yeah we're missing those because of you
and your political cronies
we should have reopened schools months
ago even the public health experts said
we should reopen schools months ago
you won't let us because you're in the
pocket of the teacher unions
because of your purely political
calculations because you
and all the other sociopath politicians
have exploited
the flu or you know the the virus
to seize an unprecedented amount of
power in this country
you you're the problem you know there
was a little remarked upon
aspect of this speech last night
that it seemed like one of those joe
freudian slips joe was
talking about the death and destruction
of it and he referred to the virus
and to natural causes leave behind loved
ones
unable to truly grieve or to heal even
to have a funeral
but i'm also thinking about everyone
else who lost this past year
to natural causes by cruel fate of
accident or other disease
they too died alone you catch that
wasn't that a little weird
well the whole time we've been told this
is a naturally occurring virus it has
nothing to do with the wuhan institute
of virology it has nothing to do
with any sort of scientific uh
formulation or anything but then he says
there's so many people who
who died of the virus so many people who
died and there are a lot of other people
who died from natural causes
w.h.o by the way says we're not going to
know the full story on the virus
for years i'm not look maybe joe misread
the teleprompter i don't know seems like
a little bit of a strange slip though
probably going to get a lot of people
chatting joe biden made it about 20
minutes
in this address to the nation which is
longer than i think a lot of people
thought it would be
this is the one advantage over
of of a president biden over say a
president trump
is when i would watch and have to cover
these sorts of speeches
with president trump they could be three
hours long they were very entertaining
so i enjoyed watching them
but i thought oh gosh am i gonna have a
three-hour joe biden speech i can't oh
wait a second it's joe biden this
thing's not going to go more than 20
minutes
joe biden's got to get to bed this is
way past his bedtime president trump
though
actually offered a very pithy statement
on the vaccine he
he sent this out just a couple of days
ago and i
i think it bears repeating on air since
he's now been de-platformed from social
media we should
get this statement as wide as possible
he writes quote i hope everyone
remembers when they're getting the kovid
19 often referred to as the china virus
vaccine
that if i wasn't president you wouldn't
be getting that beautiful shot for five
years
at best and probably wouldn't be getting
it at all i hope everyone remembers
he's probably right you know and the way
the way that i i think he probably is
right is that
all the experts were saying you're not
gonna get this vaccine it's gonna knock
six months are you crazy it's gonna take
years it's gonna go on for years and
years
and then it happened it was guided by
political process that this guy was
running so
i love that i hope everyone remembers
there's gonna be a lot of people trying
to rewrite
history i miss that guy
speaking of missing men speaking from
men missing from our culture i saw a
letter written into slate
that really caught my attention one
because this poor schlub
is showing that he
is engaging in sort of bad thoughts and
bad behaviors but also he's exemplifying
i think a lot about our culture
headline i don't want my wife to become
a stay-at-home mom
before the baby she was ambitious what
happened dear karen feeding i'm a new
father of a beautiful 10 month old girl
my wife's company has a generous
maternity leave policy
and she has been at home with her
daughter since the birth
and is scheduled to go back to work just
after her first birthday in january
but she recently told me she doesn't
want to go back to her job
she would like to be a stay-at-home
parent instead then he goes on about how
he's trying to convince her not to do
that
he says one of the things that i was
most attracted to was her ambition and
tenacity
it's really surprising to hear that her
career isn't that important to her
anymore honestly i don't want her to
quit her job
she earns about the same as i do and
while we could make ends meet on any on
my income alone
it would impact our ability to save and
we'd need to give up one of our cars
and cut back on extras that make life
more enjoyable
i also just don't want a stay-at-home
wife i really admired
her work ethic and i want her to set a
good example for our daughter too
seeing her give up like this is give up
like this
is really disappointing what should i do
signed
suddenly the breadwinner what should i
do
what should i do to quote
the godfather when he has asked that
very question by johnny fontaine
you can act like a man what's the matter
with you
what's the matter with you what man
are you this is the husband who wrote
this letter
this is punitively the husband who wrote
this letter
so many things wrong with it
his wife has this daughter and she has
the audacity
to want to raise her own daughter and
you see this is not ambitious
if the wife goes to the widget factory
and types all day
on her keyboard and just does
spreadsheets you know and makes widgets
and
well she doesn't make the widgets but
you know she's sort of supervising
the the people who have outsourced the
widget making to the
and she so she's doing that that's
really ambitious
but raising a human being it's like
whatever whatever we can you can just
hire someone to do that you see what
this guy wants to do
he wants to send his wife to work for
another man
uh so that she can make money so that he
can pay another woman
to raise his child because that's that's
the way it's supposed to work
that's ambitious otherwise you know if
the mother doesn't want to do this
she's just she's giving up and keep like
this guy i mean i get it i
i share his outrage
he's suddenly the breadwinner i mean he
makes plenty of money but he might not
be able to buy a new car next year
suddenly the breadwinner it's like this
selfish woman
expects her husband to provide for his
family
can you imagine that while she
raises his child
gosh what a what a selfish woman
what a lazy selfish woman to to want to
raise her family
and uh to want her husband to work and
support the family
this dude is everything wrong with our
culture
and even the perception of it i mean
maybe he comes by the perception
honestly
that raising a family is somehow giving
up or it's lazy or it's not ambitious
the hand that rocks the cradle is the
hand that rules the world we used to
know that
we used to know that a a
mother with her child is the
center of the world of this world that
we're all living in is the absolute
center
everything else that we do in this
material world in our economic life
all of it exists to serve that not
everybody gets to have children it's
actually hard for a lot of people to
have children for some people they don't
get that
option but
we can cast oh it's nothing let's just
let's pay somebody else to raise our kid
that's the economic model that i don't
mean just to beat up on this guy i mean
this guy is truly a schmuck he is a
a girly man as we say you know it
reminds me of the distinction between
womanly and womanish
woman lee is a woman acting
in a way that is proper for a woman to
act right it's not an insult it's a
compliment oh she's so womanly
oh my gosh when a man acts in a way that
it is proper for a woman to act
it is there's nothing admirable about
that because those qualities
are corrupted they're perverse they're
wrong it is womanish
so when you call someone a girly man
it's not an insult against girls
it's an insult against that guy because
he's acting in a way that is so perverse
but but he's he's doing something that
our whole culture is doing and it's not
just the left
it's not just the left though they sort
of instigated it in
especially in the 1970s saying that the
only values that matter are manly values
and women need to be forced to go out
and work
simone de beauvoir who was one of the
most famous
feminists ever i guess
and was also ironically the jilted
common-law wife of a notorious
philanderer the philosopher jean-paul
sartre
uh one time simone divorce was having a
debate with betty friedan
over feminism there's two prominent
feminists and friedan said yeah women
want to work good if we want to stay
home good and before said no
we can't give them that choice we have
to force women to work
because if we give them the option to
stay at home they'll take that option
and that is not conducive to liberation
the left believes that and the right
believes that
the right you know there are some
proposals now to incentivize having
families because we have a dying
population and a birth rate below
replacement
and so some people i think i think rubio
is the one who did this said
we're going to incentivize work romney's
plan of direct payments
to families who have kids that's that's
wrong we need to incentivize work we're
the party of work
no i think that if a woman
wants to raise her family that's a
really good
wonderful thing that should be
incentivized by society we should not
force her to go out and work in the
widget factory there's nothing
conservative about forcing women out of
their homes
to pay some other woman to raise their
kids so that they can go work at the
widget factory and get a paycheck
that is a totally perverse ultimately
liberal left-wing view of mankind
viewing mankind is primarily an economic
actor rather than
what we really are which is complex
people with complex relationships born
into families born into communities
who appreciate beauty who serve god who
have more going on for them than their
paychecks
my my only advice i guess would be to
this woman which is are you sure you're
you sure you've made the best choices
i'm not saying leave your husband but
you know maybe smack him around a little
bit get him to get him to shape up
speaking of womanish men this
transgender issue
is really popping up uh
more and more the left fighting back
against the right
fighting back against the left's idea
that men need to become women you know
my friend ryan anderson has this
hilariously titled book when harry
became sally responding to the
transgender moment this scholarly book
was kicked out of amazon
but amazon wouldn't give a statement
they now are giving a statement
the statement is that we have chosen not
to sell books that frame lgbtq plus
identity as a mental illness so right
they're lumping in all of these various
sexual identities so they're not going
to sell those books
but the the dsm the
central text of psychology declared
these sorts of identities a mental
illness until very recently
so presumably amazon is not going to
sell those scientific texts anymore
and presumably any conservative book any
conservative book
that questions the transgender idea
is liable to be canceled by amazon
you know one does not feel very safe
these days in a culture
that is so uh upended uh but i always
feel safe
thanks to ring so much is going on at
our front doors these days that's one
thing that has certainly not
changed for me actually with my cute
little baby
june little junior over there uh it's
happening a lot more i'm getting
food delivery because no one wants to
cook with the screaming baby i'm getting
people sending us gifts that's really
nice
and i'm getting family visitors and
depending on who that is you know maybe
you want to keep the door
open get the food or maybe you want to
keep the door closed with a ring you can
see and speak to whoever is at your door
right from your phone whether you are in
your office
maybe you're in your bedroom maybe
you're on the other side of the world
you will get notified with motion
detection even if the person at the door
doesn't ring the bell if someone stops
by or something's going on
ring is going to let you know i love
giving this out as a housewarming gift
to my friends because it makes them safe
you know i love my friends also it's not
very expensive so i get credit for a
great gift i don't have to spend a lot
but i also really like especially when
i'm on the road knowing that sweet
little alisa and june are safe
they can see who's at the door before
they open it get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit right now
ring.com knowles includes rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to upgrade your front
door and start your ring experience
that's ring.com knowles ring.com knowles
amazon's decision to ban
books that frame quote frame lgbtq plus
identity as
mental illness
is is to effect i'm not saying they're
going to ban every conservative book
i think that would be too dramatic in
practice but it is to reserve the right
to ban any conservative book that they
want because
any conservative book that touches
on human nature even
social questions political questions it
doesn't even have to be specifically on
the transgender bathrooms or girl sports
or whatever
but that touch in any way on human
nature
is liable to violate this policy
if for instance i'm writing a book of
you know it's not
not really newsy at all it's not one of
these books dealing with issues of the
moment let's say it's the most
scholarly philosophical text out there
that says that
mankind is a union of body and soul
and so you know if you're a man you're a
man you can't become a woman
that could be banned what about
religious texts
i i suppose religious texts do not
present
certain sexual identity as a
mental illness they present sexual
behavior
that derive from those ideas now we call
it identity but there the bible
and the quran would talk about behavior
they
cast them as sin the quran says
that homosexuals men who practice
homosexual acts should be punished
so is is amazon going to continue to
sell the quran
presumably they will because it would be
very politically incorrect to be in the
koran what about the bible
what about the bible that
prohibits caste castigates
cross-dressing many sexual acts
what about that is the bible going to be
banned from amazon
no then i don't think they're going to
do that probably they wouldn't mind
doing that
but it's this slow gradual process
setting the precedent establishing the
the premise
and then slowly slowly enforcing it i
bet they're gonna be a lot of
conservatives who say okay well look
either amazon's a private company they
can do what they want that's what our
founders wanted
or they'd say well you know look that's
rude
we shouldn't be rude to people and say
that transgender is a mental illness so
you know we're just not
okay that's fine and then slowly slowly
gradually
and then more quickly the left is going
to gain ground
on the topic of weird sex stuff the
latest sexual allegation against new
york democrat governor andrew cuomo
is we covered it a little bit yesterday
that andrew cuomo groped some woman it's
a vague complaint not sure that it's
true
it's now been referred to the albany
police department
so this incident may have
risen to the level of a crime now
there's no evidence that the governor is
being investigated by the police
but it the way that this is all playing
out
to me makes these accusations on sex
less credible
and it makes it clearer and clearer by
the day that this is all just about
getting rid of cuomo because of his
nursing home scandal
because democrats are implicated in that
scandal whereas they're not implicated
in him handing a hot dog a sandwich
hot dog is a sandwich by the way handing
a hot dog or sausage and pepper sandwich
to a reporter
and saying oh yeah hot dog you know it's
not about
that and the democrats are not
implicated in that so if they can
kill them for that reason they'll do it
when the real scandal here of course is
on kovid
have you followed the timetable here
first timetable cuomo made people feel
uncomfortable
that's not doing very much he kissed a
staffer once
okay that's not that's not really doing
very much uh
he he gave a hot dog to a reporter
okay that's not that's not really doing
very much
he touched someone inappropriately
okay that's not doing much he groped a
woman okay let's see
this is going to the police okay let's
see it's so
gradual and you the condemnations are so
gradual okay
now we're going to have aoc condemn him
now we're going to have
nancy pelosi question him now we're
going to have some of the state
democrats start to come out against him
now we're going to have the majority
leader in this
and of the new york state assembly and
the senate
start to come out against him now we're
gonna it's just so
obviously calculated so it's weird i'm
in a way i'm kind of defending cuomo
on these very vague personal allegations
because that's not good enough for me
look i don't think cuomo should be the
governor i want to get rid of him but i
don't want that guy to go down alone
this is not not a single single person
scandal
this is a much broader scandal and i
want a whole lot of new york state
democrats to go down for this
i want to take all the focus off these
stupid sexual allegations i want it all
to be on the nursing homes new york
politics
you'll notice is relatively controlled
it's a machine state
there's a reason that the cuomo name has
been around for a long time in new york
the reason his dad was a long time
governor too
it's a state that is it keeps a lot of
tight control in the democratic party
in other parts of our country politics
is becoming less and less
controlled in uh minnesota
a uh there is a new autonomous zone
around an area that is now dedicated to
george floyd
george floyd square there
is a militant style group that's taken
over a blocks-long
george floyd site that's created a
hostile situation this is according to
news nation
people that want to go and support the
george floyd memorial don't feel a sense
of inclusion
there is more of a military type
atmosphere over there and a sense
of fear according to one minneapolis
resident so
they're losing control this is what the
left does the left uses these sort of
paramilitary groups antifa
blm whoever is here at the george floyd
area to
upset the system create a sense of
urgency and then come in
and take more power and also
leverage this kind of violence against
republicans you saw this from the
sitting vice president kamala harris
who when when blm and her her fellow
travelers and antifa and other radical
groups were burning down the country she
said this can't stop this won't stop
this won't keep up the pressure on
republicans
now as the trial about george floyd's
death
gets underway as more evidence comes to
light as
as the facts about george floyd's life
and behavior even on that day that the
media suppressed are coming to light
maybe the cop who was involved will not
be
prosecuted or rather will not be
convicted if that is the case you can
expect a whole lot more autonomous zones
and a lot more violence
before we go i do have to mention
speaking of race hustling you remember a
while ago we talked about
that gal amanda gorman who did the slam
poem at the inauguration she did one at
the super bowl too
we went through the poem for a little
bit and i pointed out that it's a very
bad poem
and as harold bloom the literary critic
said slam poetry is the death of art
and that this is it shows how how much
our culture is decayed
because this is simply about the
appearance of poetry right you know
she's a young black woman and it's she's
performing this poem in a way the poem
itself isn't any good but it's
the the optics are so good and we're so
shallow as a culture now that's all we
care about
well i you know i hate to say i told you
so on the show i was proven right
this poem is now being translated into
uh
spanish and there was a translator
victor obioz who was hired to do this
but the editor of the barcelona
publisher told
a news agency on wednesday that once the
translation was complete
the company received a request from the
u.s publisher viking books that they had
to ditch that translation the
translation had to be done by a female
activist with african-american origins
if possible
what does the color of the or the sex of
the translator have to do with the art
with the translation of the poetry the
actual work of art
nothing of course it is you know talent
falls on
on anybody falls on people in unexpected
ways
but this isn't they know the poem's no
good it's that doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how the translation is
doesn't matter how the original poem is
they know the poem's no good it's so not
about that
it's about the appearance it's a very
shallow aspect
for our culture which is now being run
by very shallow people
who are telling us just 115 more days to
slow the spread
you know i think the world would be a
better place too if people spent as much
time reading books as they do scrolling
through
social media if you agree with me and
you have been looking for a new title to
check out
look no further the new york times
bestselling author and renowned
podcast host and supreme leader of the
multiverse
andrew clavin has released the third and
final installment of another kingdom
another kingdom is the series that drew
and i worked on years ago
and we released it just as a podcast to
see how it would do drew did all the
work writing it and then i just voiced
all the characters
and it jumped up the charts it became a
very successful podcast
it was renewed for a second and third
season it was made into a book
i happen to have done the audio book so
if you just can't get enough of these
dulcet tones
you can get the audiobook this series is
one of the rare trilogies
it gets better with each and every book
the first one's terrific the next one's
better the third one is really
magnificent i kid you not
when i was reading these in the studio
for the audiobook
at least one time with each book i
teared up
i did you're gonna make fun of me you're
gonna call me a girly man i did because
it's
a really really tremendous tremendous
work go check that out also you know
we've announced on election night now
the wait is over candace owens is
premiering on her new daily wire show
candace if it does very well i think
we're going to rename all the shows just
our first names you'll be
michael ben ben one syllable it's a
little tougher that way
uh seriously this is going to be a great
show candace you know her she founded
the blexit movement
she is changing the narrative
surrounding america's minority
communities she's the author of the new
york times
bestseller blackout how black american
make its second escape
from the democrat plantation join
candace every week
as she covers a host of different topics
from the latest trends to hard-hitting
news
get to know the real candice funny
authentic and insightful find out why
the left loves to hate candace
by going to dailywire.com subscribe use
code candace for 25
off we'll be right back with the mailbag
first question in the mail bag from
veronica hey michael
love your show thank you for all that
you do i'm curious as to what your
thoughts are about the deportation of
former nazi concentration camp guard
friedrich karl berger do you think that
his deportation was the right thing
to do particularly thinking about him
being a 19 year old at the time
who was likely brainwashed by nazi
propaganda throughout a good portion of
his childhood
could this situation in a way be
compared to former u.s presidents and
military leaders who are being canceled
for owning slaves
looking forward to hearing your thoughts
no i don't think it's comparable
i don't think that uh the this former
nazi is
uh is comparable in any way to george
washington however it is a it is a
complex issue
when you're 92 years old
what responsibility do you have for the
things that you did when you were 19.
i think what this comes to is going to
be a question of
justice mercy sure and
and justice so a lot of nazis fled and
they escaped
justice and perhaps they led good lives
perhaps they tried to make amends but
this gets to a point that roger scrutin
made the great the late great roger
scrutin a conservative philosopher
who actually i got to i hosted an event
at the roger scrutin legacy foundation
yesterday
with the jacob rees-mogg the the leader
of the house of commons and robbie
george at princeton which i think you
can check out soon i think it's going to
go online but
anyway scrutin made this point he said
that civilization depends on
confession and forgiveness
our ability to confess our sins to say
you know i did this and i
have the sense of sin and i recognize it
it was wrong and when you do that you
sacrifice your pride
which is one of the reasons that the
sacrament of confession is so important
it is
you it is an action by which you must
sacrifice your pride
and acknowledge your sins and then
forgiveness is when you say okay i
forgive you and you sacrifice your
resentment
which we all cherish as well we cherish
our many resentments so you both
sacrifice something
and you move on together uh as a people
you do have to conf you know you have to
confess your sins you you have to in
some way seek justice
um which i don't know if this guy did
seems like this guy didn't do it it
seems like he was just kind of living on
the lam for 70 years and then the past
comes back
and your past sins come back to visit
you again
the way that this does tie into cancer
culture though is that cancer culture
has totally removed the ability
for confession and forgiveness in the
past if you made a mistake
you'd apologize you said okay i
shouldn't have done that i'm sorry and
then we'd say okay
that's fine we we accept your apology
and that's why america is the country of
second chances
or it was but now you know you can't do
that if you're if you're in politics
and you apologize in any way you will
be destroyed if you're in public life
and you apologize in any way you will be
destroyed that's something that actually
has changed
in recent years because we are no longer
willing to forgive
as a people we're no real no longer
willing to sacrifice our resentment
actually
our school curricula are being
reformulated to stoke
resentment the the grievance studies
uh programs that have cropped up at
universities and now are even infecting
uh high schools and middle schools and
elementary schools that was what harold
bloom who is a liberal literary critic
he called it the school of resentment
the purpose of it is to stoke
resentment meanwhile on the other side
of that the confession
confessional side we now have
transformed our culture from one in
which we understood that pride
is the queen of all vices right it's the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins
now we believe that pride is a virtue
pride
is now celebrated in parades right
it used to be the case that pride was a
a stand-in for for
sort of gay parades but now it's really
surpassed even that
narrow sexual question now it's just all
sorts of pride fat pride skinny pride
pride is considered to be a good thing
but pride is not pride is what caused
the fall of mankind so
in in that sort of a culture then yes i
suppose there is there is a sort of uh
there is a tie-in to cancel culture here
but really i think the question
ultimately is one of
justice and mercy will and grace
in a right society what you would be
able to do is confess your sins
take your punishment and move on and
then we would all move on together but
if you
refuse to confess your sins if you
refuse to take your punishment if you
refuse to do your penance
and if you if you if we on the other
hand refuse to to forgive then you can't
have that society
from jacob ciao signorinos i was
watching a video of casey cole of
franciscan
explaining that the only way of
salvation is to help the poor
he was explaining that christ also asked
if people fed him and clothed him and so
on
he said it is not enough just by
practicing the sacraments and and
practicing
and preaching the gospel would you agree
that helping the
poor is important to attain salvation
uh well uh we are saved
by the grace of god right and then and
then responding to god's grace
in an act of faith so that's how we do
it and so
this this is not simply done as an act
of the the intellect right there there
is an action of the intellect here but
faith also looks like something christ
says there are many people who will
call me lord lord who i do not know you
know who will not be saved
so it's not merely an act of speech in
the intellect it actually
has to be embodied ours is an
incarnational faith so
i haven't listened to what this
franciscan has said but in as much as
he's saying that
uh our the the virtue of the theological
virtue of charity
looks like something and our faith looks
like something and it impels us to give
alms and
sure okay that makes sense but if he's
saying i suspect he's not if he's
implying though
that somehow you are saved by the act of
giving money to the homeless guy that
would be the the heresy of pelagius that
would be
uh salvation through works which uh is
is not true i i suspect that that uh
this
franciscan would be formed well enough
not to be saying that but i can
understand how that could be
misinterpreted so yeah that that would
not be the case
from kelly hey michael first of all
congrats on your baby boy thank you
so i'm wondering it was it was dr seuss
then a few looney tunes characters
what pop culture books characters etc do
you think will be cancelled
next thank you
huh i said well i mean this is a little
bit of a cop-out but i think more dr
seuss will be canceled
and i think more looney tunes will be
canceled and i think that
more disney will be cancelled too you're
already seeing some attacks on disney
there was a headline the other day that
disney is a
park of privilege and it's there's not
equity there so you're going to see some
of that crop up as well
the reason that those guys are going to
be cancelled is one because
some of the cultural observations that
they make or even the just some of the
jokes that they make
contravene and contradict the the
politically correct orthodoxy of the day
and the left can't tolerate that not for
any principle just because it's a
challenge to their to their power
but also i was just re-watching fantasia
i was re-watching some of the old
looney tunes uh cartoons that were
put to classical music and they're
really brilliant they're really really
brilliant because they
they are educating people they are
entertaining and educating toward
people's
higher faculties right it's not just a
bunch of
cheap jokes and you know constant
feeding of our lower appetites they're
much higher when you watch fantasia it's
really an
art truly an artistic experience and the
same is true of those old looney tunes
cartoons and that's
something the left i think really does
not want to have happen
this is why the left is always pushing
toward our base or desires trying to
remove
most notably prohibitions on obscenity
because when you can arouse people's
prurient interest when you can arouse
people's kind of baser
desires then they're not going to be
thinking with their
higher higher reason and they're going
to be easier to control so i can see
that happening and it's it
they'll come up with some excuse about
you know race or sex or something but
that's going to be the real reason
they're doing it from matt michael in
the past you've said the only good
argument against the existence of god is
the problem of evil
and i think this is a good point i'll
put a pause right there i think it's the
best argument against the existence of
god but
actually i think it's i think theodicy
the the
problem of suffering and evil is an
argument for god i think it's a much
better argument for god than against god
but
anyway see your point uh however i'm
curious
what do you think is the best argument
against christianity and why do you
think that argument falls short love the
show keep up the good work well
the best argument against christianity
is that
uh christ is not who he says he is
right and c.s lewis answered this with
the three l's he says christ can either
be
a lunatic a liar or the lord
so either he's just a complete nut and
the things he's saying are not true but
he really believes them or he knows that
what he's saying is not true
but he's deceiving people anyway to what
end
i don't you know to the point of the
cross okay or he really is the lord i
think these fall apart because one when
you
encounter christ in the gospels he
doesn't seem like a lunatic
and the people around him don't behave
as though he's a lunatic
as to the liar point it's hard to see
what he would gain
from his behavior he he knows that he is
there to die
to go to the cross so if he's just a con
man he's really not behaving
like a con man and then the the only
other option is that he's the lord
now there's this fourth option which is
that it's legend i've had some jewish
friends of mine say this well no michael
it's just a legend we can't you know we
can't rely on the gospels they were
written
so much later and you know it's just
there's no evidence that this stuff
really happened
i think that falls flat i think that's a
little bit bit of a cope
you know for uh for people who are who
don't want to engage in the first three
arguments as well because
one we have so many eyewitnesses to it
you so you've got the gospel accounts
which are
which were written not particularly long
after christ's death they were all
written
actually rather soon after christ's
death and resurrection
but you have uh hundreds and hundreds of
eyewitnesses to the resurrection itself
you have a non-biblical accounts of
christ
and early christianity you have the
lives of the apostles
which don't make any sense if it's a
legend why these
why these people would go to travel to
the ends of the earth
going to their deaths
in most cases because of a legend
because of a joke because
because either they were all fooled wow
it's amazing that they were all fooled
at once or that
i guess the legend argument requires
that they were fooling everybody else
but again to what end so that st thomas
could die in india
so that peter could be crucified upside
down so that paul could have his head
cut off
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
so i you know i
that all the challenges to to
christianity would be
challenges on on the fact of christ um
and his
and his life and the miracles and but i
just don't think they really hold up to
scrutiny
one way to think of it is that uh
another good argument i think tim keller
made this the protestant
pastor he he said that
if this were just a legend then the
gospels would have been written
differently
but when you when you read great myths
and great legends
they read differently than the gospels
do the gospels read much more like
journalism right the gospels are not
really so much an act of poetry or
philosophy as they are an act of
journalism and it's why in some details
there
seem to be some discrepancies between
the because they're accounts it'd be
like reading the washington post
and the new york times well it's quite
the opposite of that actually
because the gospels are true and the uh
washington post in the new york times
you know are
are not but it's why they're the
different gospels
actually are focusing on different
aspects they're seeing things from a
different vantage to me these are all
pretty good arguments that uh it's true
from paul dear michael
dear my question for you involves a
burden i've been carrying since the
summer of 2019 a burden which has grown
heavier with each new daily wire
membership here that i've joined
in the summer of 2019 i fell in love
with a girl in a bernie sanders t-shirt
it happens to the best of us i will
spare you the details but nothing
long-term ultimately transpired for
reasons having nothing to do with
politics
the weight of knowing i looked the other
way on the bernie sanders t-shirt
however as well as the fear that i might
do it again remain with me to this day
i'm overcome with guilt and shame is my
great sin forgivable
how can i live with myself how can i
prevent this from ever happening again
to myself my family
my friends i'll be forever indebted to
you for any wisdom you can provide
i beg you please not mention this as
matt to matt as my actions would surely
banish me forever from his channel
i come to you as i know you were a man
of grace yours truly
we've all done it i remember william f
buckley jr
great conservative was on woody allen's
show one time and he was asked by a
young girl he said
what uh do you approve of miniskirts and
his answer was
on you i do i think that
on good legs are always in good taste so
you know these things happen i actually
think that
this is an opportunity for you not to be
like this poor schlub from slate
magazine
complaining about how his wife isn't
making enough money for him
i would this this is an opportunity for
you if you see a cute gal
wearing that bernie shirt you spy her
and her cute little blue hair across the
room
with her ridiculous hipster glasses on
you know and her her uh air of
sort of feisty resentment at the world
to look at her and say you know listen
you're a cutie i know you've got a heart
of gold deep down there somewhere
and i in my leadership capacity i'm
going to guide you
toward truth i'm going to guide you away
from your your misconceptions that seems
to me a wonderful challenge
uh but make sure you can do that you
know otherwise you're really setting
yourself up for trouble do not wind up
like another prince harry okay
that's our show i'm michael noel's the
michael knowles show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin
show you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin